(dreamy music)
- [Narrator] When it's cold outside,
there's nothing like a warm
bath to take off the chill.
And these monkeys have found a great one.
The Jigokudani Valley in
Japan is buried in snow
for almost one third of the year.
The area is more commonly
known as Hell's Valley,
named for its high
altitude, jagged cliffs,
and bubbling hot springs
that fill the air with steam.
The local Japanese
macaques or snow monkeys
have found an interesting way to adapt
to these cold conditions.
In the early 1960s, these
clever and curious creatures
moved down from the higher forests
and tested the water of
the natural hot springs.
They have been using
them as a spa to warm up
in the winter months ever since.
These snow monkeys like company.
Their average group is
typically 41 monkeys,
but can range from 10 to 161.
They're not picky eaters, either.
They'll eat just about everything
from seeds, plants and fruits,
or a handout from a mischievous tourist.
Even in the high mountains of Japan,
these clever critters have
found a great way to relax.
Spa day, anyone?
(upbeat music)
(electronic music)